alright this time I'm gonna get a little
bit it's my own particular brand of
geekery and I'm gonna talk about Doctor
Who I'm gonna rank the doctors we'll
start at the bottom we'll work our way
up number 11
Colin Baker the sixth doctor I've only
seen a couple of the ones that he's been
in but having watched who are supposedly
the best ones that he's in the guy just
doesn't do it for me
he is grading he lacks the charm needed
to pull off the doctor because a lot of
the things that people complain about
him the fact that he's arrogant Denny's
got a temper and you know he's very
dismissive of humans and also well so
are most of the doctors the difference
is is they have the charm to get away
with a Colin Baker just doesn't really
have that moving on to number ten
William Hartnell the first doctor again
I feel slightly guilty putting him so
down towards the bottom then character
was still being formed at that point and
William Hartnell was again a bit of a
glump towards the tail end of his run as
the doctor he did start to get that sort
of little mischievous wink he definitely
planted the seeds of a lot of stuff and
obviously he was the first template but
just taking the the performance the take
on the character unto itself he's just
not as much fun number nine
peter davidson i think what it is about
Peter Davison that never quite clicked
for me is it feels like an act and he
did all the right things he he had the
right amount of trepidation for the
character who's conflicted the right
moments he had that little bit of
arrogance that the doctor should have
but he was also heroic and there was a
lot of good choices made in playing him
but it just didn't feel natural I kind
of wish he'd come back and do a bit more
stuff because if you see him in time
crash which is more recent he is
wonderful I love him in that and he at
that point in his life had the knack
Kronus that I feel he just didn't have
at the time he was actually playing the
doctor number eight Jon Pertwee the
third doctor the reason he's not ranked
higher is he's he's a little too action
hero for me that said the man was
infinitely charming
I mean charisma just oozed off this guy
he had this he'd give this little sly
wing to the side usually after he's just
insulted the human race as a whole and
you're like oh I can't be mad at you you
just compared us to Apes but I don't
care I look at that smile
moving up the ladder we come to
Sylvester McCoy the Seventh Doctor he
works better in the later ones I filled
in the early ones the early ones they
they weren't quite sure what to do with
him yet but as his tenure as the doctor
progressed he started to get this little
hint of Machiavellian plotting of
scheming of just general darkness about
the guy just behind the sort of
masquerade of Pleasant slightly bumbling
character and it's a it's a really
interesting contrast to watch and now we
come to doctor number eight Paul McGann
if you want to talk about somebody who
really got the shaft but still gave a
great performance and if you doubt that
he would have been a fantastic doctor to
keep coming back just watch his face and
the nuance and the joy just this glee
about him and it's really really
wonderful to see next on the hit list
Christopher Eccleston the Ninth Doctor a
bit like Sylvester McCoy he had the sort
of dual nature to him he had a very
outward very pleasant very joyous front
but just you scratched just beneath the
source of the surface of that and he was
really really damaged it adds a gravity
to his performance in his portrayal that
works really really well getting towards
the top Tom Baker the man was just from
another planet it just poured out of him
and he was so perfect for that role he
was clever he was funny he was witty and
he
and this wonderful sense of childishness
just everything with this wide-eyed oh
ooh and it was infectious and he was
really really great
number three Patrick Troughton the
second doctor Patrick Troughton really
truly set the mold for what we expect
the doctor to be he was a bit of a
coward he would put on all of all of
these affectations to make his enemies
assume he was an idiot which is
something that they that so many of the
doctors who have come along since him
have done most of them have in fact he
has this warmth to him that a lot of the
doctors don't have actually you still
had the sense of almost sort of
defensive superiority that he felt about
himself and it was it was just endearing
it brings us down to two so who came out
on top well let's start with the
runner-up David Tennant number 10 David
Tennant is my doctor he's the one that
made me fall in love with his show his
love of this material and of this
character just pours through every frame
that he is ever in but he's not my
number one pick Matt Smith is my number
one pick and here's the reason Matt
Smith in addition to being wonderfully
charming and just a lot of fun
he brought the alien back to the doctor
because David Tennant as much as I love
him he's kind of gone native a little
bit and it makes sense it makes total
sense and I don't question that decision
and how to play him but what I look at
the overall scheme of the doctor
I like that slight other worldliness
that's slight there's a little bit off
and Tennant
his performance felt a little too human
Matt Smith brought back
weird and in all honesty I think part of
it is is a narcissistic thing because
Matt Smith's my age it's almost like
vicariously I get to be the doctor and
that's why he's my personal number one I
would not begrudge anybody for their
number one cuz this is a personal choice
this is not an objective list but there
it is right now councils adjourned